bonsoir à tous bienvenue aux tedx ue
donc je me présente à l'iem m'a dit donc
pourquoi vous êtes vous
soit c'est pour savoir quand aura lieu
enfin l'octogone donc pour rappeler
l'octogone c'est quoi c'est en fait tout
simplement deux chanteurs contemporains
d'un côté donc elie yaffa que nous sous
le nom de booba et de l'autre au cou
yuna khoury armand connu sous le nom de
caris ils se sont dit donc ils vont
régler leurs comptes
autour d'un l'octogone qui est en fait
le lieu le pourrait dire en fait celle
de l'emplacement
donc le ring en forme non que d'octogone
avec +8 côté sur laquelle ils vont en
fait donc bien régler leurs comptes
bon avant de vous dire qu'on aura les
l'octogone je vous parlais d'une de ce
très important qui va vous permettre de
comprendre pourquoi je parle de loto de
ce soir
cette notion c'est la pugnacité en effet
rapidement qu'est ce que la pugnacité
c'est le fait tout simplement fait donc
d'être persévérant donc de d'avoir
l'esprit combatif et la pugnacité je
sais ce que c'est puisque j'ai passé
plusieurs formes ont permis donc vous
explique un petit peu j'habite à saint
benoît donc mes études je faisais au
tampon donc pendant près de 8 ans j'ai
pas le permis donc du coup je bats vous
imaginez comment ça se passe donc on
prend le bus à 5 heures du matin on
arrive de l'autre côté il faut reprendre
un autre bus ça pendant huit ans et donc
vous imaginez avec quelle appréhension
quelle motivation même j'avais d'avoir
mon permis puisque ça pouvait plus on
pouvait plus malgré le soutien des
parents me disaient allez vas-y continue
mais
la ville ont permis à la région c'est un
peu compliqué et donc je me suis dit bon
il faut que je passe il me le faut
absolument fait et je me souviendrai
toujours de la première fois que j'ai
passé c'était c'était mémorable fait
vous explique donc j'arrive un peu en
avance donc j'arrive je rentre dans le
véhicule
donc là dans le véhicule donc je règle
mon siège
les rétroviseurs donc je scrute un petit
peu donc l'environnement
donc je vois en fait donc les pannes ou
la circulation il ya même une fille qui
me regarde avec insistance
peut-être qu'elle se dit à ce gala et sa
grinta premier coulis et donc
donc je me remémore un petit peu les
conseils de mon moniteur tranquillement
ben justement cette fille qui m'ont
regardé avec insistance rapproche dit
peut-être que avec à petit quelques
petits conseils
donc elle se rapproche donc les maîtres
la vitre donc bonjour oui bonjour
comment allez vous très très bien
excusez moi de vous déranger c'est juste
pour vous informer que votre moniteur et
l'examinateur en attendant l'autre
véhicule
non je pense pas si si si si et là vous
vous êtes dans mon véhicule
ah d'accord bah je vais mourir ailleurs
alors est donc là je me retrouve dans le
bon véhicule
j'explique pas le stress bon j'ai essayé
d'être le plus carré possible mais comme
dit créole que le club est dans mon dos
me dis moi tu es là là là là un plat
n'est bon le moniteur me regarde j'ai
compris l'examinateur monsieur m'a dit
donc faut y aller un parce que le permis
c'est aujourd'hui donc je rentre dans le
véhicule donc je démarre la voiture donc
tranquillement ça va tranquillement je
cale
c'est ben ali c'est le stress fosseux
faut se remettre bien on voyait arriver
donc je repars bon jeu recale encore
chez [ __ ] [ __ ]
en fait la seule chose que je pensais
c'est si le moniteur y met les pieds sur
les pédales
je suis mort c'est fini des mauves
heures et donc je me disais peut-être
qu'il y aurait un embouteillage
au bout des femmes gagnent faire gagner
plus facilement mon permis effectivement
j'ai regardé en bouteille h mais avec un
démarrage en côte
donc je me dis ah ouais bon là c'est
tout ou rien donc je me concentre je me
concentre puisqu'on est sur une pente
donc c'est quand même assez tendue et je
décolle
sauf que c'est pas moi qui fait décoller
la voiture et donc je me retrouve à
devoir repasser le permis donc j'ai pris
un peu de réflexion je me suis dit bon
est ce que je me revois encore les
reprendre le bus etc puisque entre temps
je n'oublie de reprendre le bus il a pu
durer donc je me suis dit bon je vais y
aller je repartis une deuxième fois
cette fois ci avec le même moniteur est
dans le bon véhicule
mais cette fois-ci ben je sais pas
j'avais une appréhension par rapport à
la dernière fois j'ai calé sur calais
est recalé et au final il marque allait
donc j'ai dû repasser une troisième fois
mais la troisième fois je me suis dit
bon tu as passé une fois t'as pas eu
tu as passé deux fois t'as pas eu qu'est
ce que tu fais me suis dit que j'ai
besoin de ce permis là parce que cette
période me permettra d'avancer également
dans la vie et donc je me suis dit bon
il faut y aller donc j'ai repris m
seront pris en main j'ai repris des
cours donc
je me suis entraîné entraîné donc juste
pour info en fait là le jour où j'ai
passé mon permis
c'est la catastrophe la durée un peu
avant en fait je train de faire une
marche arrière mais je n'arrivais pas à
faire les marches arrière moins huit
hommes dix ali tu as un repas se termine
13ème fois tu arrives pas faire une
marche arrière
j'ai fait non il joue pas il me dit
calme toi tu vas y arriver et confiance
en toi
mais bon tu arrives pas le faire une
marche arrière une heure avant ton
permis c'est un peu compliqué et donc du
coup ben j'y suis allé donc je rentre
dans la voiture en plus avaient encore
troisième fois le même moniteur
donc je me dis bon j'espère qu'il a bien
retenu que j'ai un peu évolué et donc la
jambe dans le véhicule
donc je fais mes amis rond point mais
intersection je cale pas du tout et là
je les ai eus ce permis donc
effectivement donc ce qui me permet en
fait bouillir ça c'est que je me suis
rendu compte que tout simplement la
pugnacité la persévérance ça a payé
c'est le fait j'aurais pu me dire voilà
j'arrête mais non non je me suis dit bon
faut y aller il faut y aller toute façon
j'en ai besoin
et si j'abandonne maintenant
ça va pas marrant j'ai justement je vous
parle en fait de pugnacité puisqu'il ya
eu d'autres expériences qui m'ont montré
la pugnacité
donc ça va beaucoup aider un exemple
simple en 2013 j'ai participé à la
startup weekend donc je vous recommande
si vous voulez vous lancer dans un super
super aventure
donc je vous explique un petit peu le
concept vous arrivez dans la start-up
tranquillement donc vous avez en fait un
projet à présenter
vu que mon ami m'a un peu on va dire
poussé y aller il m'a dit allez vas-y tu
as super projet sur les applications de
bus
vu que j'étais très très longtemps dans
le bus donc je me suis dit bon c'est le
moment de voilà de le montrer donc je
dis bon on va y aller
arrivé donc on présente son projet
chacun le présent il y avait à peu près
une vingtaine de candidats et pour
passer à l'étape au-dessus donc pour
pouvoir travailler sur la start up
il fallait en fait avoir un certain
nombre de points
donc moi je n'ai récolté 16 et après ça
en fait j'ai on a rencontré une personne
qu'il est plus ou moins le même projet
plus ou moins similaires et on a mit
média libre mais les autres équipes
comme ça allait pouvoir avancer lui ça
me permet d'avancer a appuyé sur son
projet je vois mais je ne connais pas
juge mais vas-y à lisser leurs ceintures
week-end donc on est là pour pour
avancer donc je me suis dit pourquoi pas
donc on est parti non ensemble dans la
voiture on en connaît avancé au tout
début ça allait mais au fur et à mesure
on s'entendait pas sur certains points
et donc je me suis dit mais bon qu'est
ce que je fais j'arrête ça ne commence à
me commence à me saouler j'arrive pas en
fait à à pouvoir bien discuté avec lui
on n'arrive pas à s'entendre mais j'ai
dit c'est de continuer quand même j'ai
continué jeudi fut vinasse top week-end
avec mon projet je vais le mener à bien
en fait est tout simplement
donc on a réussi on a gagné la sorte au
pick n j'étais super content moi même je
pensais pas on était parti d'un mauvais
départ au final on devient lauréat donc
quelques jours plus tard donc la
personne avec qui qui va lui revenir mon
équipe m'appelle oui bonjour ali oui
bonjour
en fait j'y réfléchis un peu à la 7'
picken donc si on travaille sur ce
projet d'implication pour moi c'est 90
10 g comment 90 10 tu m'as dit oui 90 10
à 90 pour moi et 10 pour toi j'ai fait
ou j'ai pas très bons en maths mais là
c'est un peu bizarre que ce qu'ils me
proposent là et j'ai même proposé bon
ont fait 49 56 tu veux mais vu il m'a
dit non je fais mon chef mais ça va je
vais pas qu'aux sites travaillent avec
lui donc du coup on a en fait chacun est
parti de son côté et quelques temps plus
tard une société a lancé l'application
en question et quelques temps [ __ ]
encore j'ai l'université du tampon qui
m'appelle ali bonjour oui j'ai un jeune
homme qui voudrait lancer un projet tour
et un petit projet donc pour son projet
de d'étudiants et on aimerait en fait
que tu l'aide dans ce projet là en fait
il veut créer une association d'anciens
élèves
j'ai dit ouais pourquoi pas et pas de
soucis mais après il me dit par contre
il faut que je travaille qu'une personne
gbc qui la personne
mehdi ben hassine personne que tu
connais pas j'ai un bon et c'est qui ça
je ne sais pas il est comme en ajoie
mais tu l'as pas vu tu l'a jamais
rencontrée d'accord et donc là je me dis
ce jour là en plus on était le dise
j'étais en train de jouer sur mon
téléphone et j'avais fait 90 j'ai fait
90 10
c'est pas j'ai dit bon je vais pas
m'arrêter à la donc j'ai dit bon ok on y
va donc on commence le projet donc on
commence à travailler ensemble et le
projet tutoré donc qui devait tenir un
semestre au final ça a duré trois ans on
a créé on n'a plus lancé ensemble le ce
qu'on appelle le réseau et rca donc le
réseau de compétences pour l'avenir où
tous les deuxièmes mercredis du mois on
en fait on organisait une mini
conférence avec un entrepreneur qui
présentait donc son sa vision du marché
son objectif son produit ou tout
simplement en fait présenter sa société
tout ça dans les systèmes donc de
d'entrepreneurs et de start up heures
puisqu'il y avait des ça permettait en
fait de faire du réseautage
donc la conclusion est là c'est que
j'aurais pu me dire ah ouais t'es jamais
à narguer me connaît pas il est mon
travail avec mes non non je me suis dit
non il faut que j'avance il faut que je
parte au delà de mes limites en fait
comme l'a si bien dit voltaire les
préjugés sont les ennemis du bon sens
hélas ce proverbe la prend tout son sens
puisque j'aurais pu m'arrêter à la mais
j'ai dit non je vais aller plus de
l'avant
bon bon je veux être excusé je vous
raconte tout ça mais en fait vous êtes
venu où ce soir pour savoir quand aura
lui l'octogone donc pour moi en fait
sincèrement l'octogone il a lieu tous
les jours chaque fois en fait que vous
vous lancez d'un projet il ya un
octogone puisque vous vous battez contre
vous même il ya un lien vous allez en
fait de rencontrer des barrières qui
vont vous dire non il ya saria ça tu
veux pas faire ça
ouais non tu as ta mwen sat dont il y
aura toujours des bars yade est toujours
en fait des percées qui vont soit vous
ralentir soit vous allez en fait manquer
de compétences aux autres
est ce qu'il faut faire c'est que
dites-vous juste quand vous allez vous
lancer dans un projet où elle rentre
d'une toute petite voix qui va vous dire
hamon si le contrat est là ce que vous
allez faire si vous allez prendre une
feuille une feuille format a4
vous allez prendre un stylo vous allez
dessinée à l'octogone sans règles ont
pas mal ev et sur chacun de ses côtés
chacun des côtés de l'octogone de
l'année à frire une difficulté que
j'allais rencontrer durant votre projet
et au fur et à mesure de l'avancée votre
projet il va pouvoir en fait supprimer
puisque vous allez rencontrer vous allez
pouvoir
face à ce prix ce problème puisque vous
allez pouvoir le surmonter en fait tout
ça pour vous dire que la pugnacité
c'est ce qui m'a permis de sortir out of
the box c'est ce qui m'a pas permis en
fait d'avancé non le les projets donc
d'avoir le permis
de créer un réseau assez assez
intéressant qui permet d'échanger donc
de développer en fait encore
l'écosystème des start up à la réunion
et je terminerai sur une citation d'un
m.go bois housni qui disait il faut
relativiser ces difficultés pour faire
évoluer ses facultés
merci à tous